ist sie im bereich der nasa eine
sensation die eine revolution in der
raumfahrt möglich macht konkret werden
mikrowellen dabei in einem gegen
förmigen wohnraum aus kupfer hin und her
bewegt so soll ein schub erzeugt werden
quasi ein treibstoff loser antrieb der
nur mit sonnenenergie funktionieren
würde der nicht nur eine kolonie auf dem
mars sondern auch die erkundung des
äußeren sonnensystems leichter machen
könnte und jetzt gibt es eine neue
studie dazu klick zum zweiten fiction
herzlich willkommen und vielen dank für
den themenvorschlag auf whatsapp dort in
der community
das große problem der raumfahrt und der
erkundung des weltalls ist einfach seine
gigantische größe die distanzen zwischen
den zahlreichen himmelskörpern sind
einfach enorm für uns menschen sind sie
ohne warp antrieb mit
überlichtgeschwindigkeit kaum zu
schaffen
jedenfalls nicht in zeiträumen die wir
uns erträumen die anderen systeme die
wir bislang kennen brauchen viel zu viel
treibstoff das alles stellt uns vor in
bezug auf unsere vision ja vor riesige
logistische probleme zu schön um wahr zu
sein erschien dann im jahr 2014
die idee der nasa ein neuartiges
antriebssystem das kein treibstoff
braucht nach bestimmten quanten
prinzipien funktioniert und das obwohl
es die bekannten grund gesetze der
physik verletzt ein science fiction
antrieb der vielleicht alle unsere
raumfahrt visionen wahr machen könnte
doch schon damals war trotz aller
euphorie klar
die nasa hatte keinesfalls einen solchen
neuen antrieb realisiert einen
prototypen oder gar ein neues raumschiff
gebaut der kurze bericht der
veröffentlicht wurde bezog sich auf das
sogenannte e m drive konzept des
britischen ingenieurs roger gioia der
hatte ein gerät entwickelt das eine
antriebskraft ohne treibstoff erzeugen
kann und dass nur durch die reflektion
von mikrowellen in einem kegel hohlraum
demnach würden sich wechselwirkungen mit
teilchen und quantenfluktuationen
ergeben die diese kraft erzeugen doch
das arbeit wurde hart kritisiert
beispielsweise für einige enthaltene
fehler die er abstritt aber auch dafür
dass er seine ergebnisse nicht in einer
wissenschaftlichen zeitschrift
veröffentlicht hatte die nachdem peer
review verfahren arbeitet also wo
wissenschaftler vor der veröffentlichung
die eingereichten studien überprüfen ja
doch dagegen standen wiederum die
experimente eines chinesischen
forschungsteams das tatsächlich solch
eine antriebskraft gemessen haben wollte
auch das entsprechende nasa team um
herald weit hatte bei ihren
untersuchungen einen solchen effekt
aufgespürt auch wenn dieser etwas
kleiner war als der den ihre
chinesischen kolleginnen und kollegen
gefunden hatten
in ihrem wirklich ziemlich kurzen
bericht schreibt die nasa von
verschiedenen tests durchgeführt wurden
um klarzustellen dass das messeergebnis
nicht von einem anderen effekt
hervorrufen oder beeinflusst worden war
zitat test results indicate that the
president quit procter design ist für
jüdische volk das is not a tribute to
any klassiker elektromagnetik phänomenta
defoe ist potenziell demonstrierten
interaction with it quantum ray
cambridge usa
die gemessene kraft seit demnach also
nicht durch klassische magnetische
phänomene zu erklären
stattdessen sei möglicherweise eine
interaktion mit virtuellem quanten
plasma anzunehmen
in dem kurzen bericht von 2014 ist also
wirklich nur von den messungen die rede
und das nasa forschungsteam gab zu
diesem reinen laborexperiment keine
physikalische begründung oder
erklärungen ab der arbeit zufolge
jedenfalls könnte der m3 für einen
treibstoff losen antrieb sorgen den
benötigten strom für die mikrowellen
könnte man im weltraum beispielsweise
durch solarenergie gewinnen und ihre
reflexion sorge dann für den schub doch
die kritik an dem experiment riss nicht
ab schließlich war der gemessen effekt
sehr sehr klein und die meisten
forscherinnen und forscher weltweit
glaubt er an einen messfehler als an
eine sensation und genau das konnte etwa
zwei jahre später überprüft werden denn
die ergebnisse von nasa-forscher white
und den kolleginnen und kollegen wurden
dann offiziell in einer fachzeitschrift
veröffentlicht die wissenschafts
community begann mit der
qualitätskontrolle und im mai 2018 kam
dann eine große studie der universität
dresden heraus sie hatte man sich
jahrelang mit der mysteriöse schubkraft
beschäftigt und den ganzen versuch unter
anderem auch in einer vakuumkammer
laufen lassen so sollte man alle äußeren
einflüsse ausschließen zudem wurden die
meisten vorgänge automatisiert und mit
einer extrem genauen fusions waage auch
die kleinsten schubkräfte messbar
gemacht und tatsächlich am anfang
stimmte die datenlage mit den
messergebnissen der nasa über ein durch
die reflektion der mikrowellen entsteht
im kegel inneren eine kleine schubkraft
so schien es doch jetzt haltet euch fest
diese konnte das forschungsteam auch
messen wenn gar kein schuh produziert
wurde
heißt also ganz konkret selbst wenn
keine mikrowellen im kegel vorhanden
waren ließ sich diese kraft messen
das fazit des dresdener forschungsteams
ist deswegen eindeutig der effekt
entsteht nicht durch irgendwelche
mysteriösen wechselwirkungen zwischen
dem quanten vakuum und den mikrowellen
sondern lässt sich auf eine ganz andere
wechselwirkung zurückführen nämlich auf
die uns bekannte wechselwirkung zwischen
dem erdmagnetfeld und den stromführenden
kabeln des em drives und ihr könnt euch
vorstellen auch dieses experiment wird
nicht von allen gefeiert und na klar ein
perfektes experiment gibt es nicht und
vielleicht lässt sich auch an der
aktuellen studie etwas finden was
theoretisch noch retten könnte ja wenn
ihr keine videos dazu und zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
endet mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht er
hier die kaputte abo box auf youtube und
verpasst kein video mehr
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
noch vor allen anderen vom neuesten
video täglich garantiert einfach hier
draufklicken und am besten auch meinen
schwestern anna klicks um social and
media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste
aus der social media welt dafür hier
klicken aber nicht die schwimmer die
glocke vergessen und dir geht es weiter
mit dafür auch draufklicken neuer
revolutionärer raumfahrt am trieb
bis dann bleibt an